hallo mein name ist luca und das ist das
was wir im heutigen video machen werden
meine damen und herren ist findet hinter
der kamera und hat youtuber starter
packs vorbereitet also beispielsweise
einen youtuber den er uns jetzt sagen
wird hat dann vier bilder und diese vier
bilder beschreiben diesen youtuber und
wir raten abwechseln welche bilder das
sein könnten
richtig ja besser hätte man es nicht
sagen können erste den ich mir
ausgesucht habe ist sturm waffeln ich
würde sagen einfach nur warte erstmal
das ist korrekt
also ich würde sagen bei sturm waffe ist
auf jeden fall sonnenbad lange haare ein
dreieck sein logo korrekt was ja keine
ahnung der haut richtig morgens immer
guten morgen nein
janácek jeden tag mit prostituierten
twitter finden das immer noch so ich
habe eigentlich schon gewonnen aber ich
sage das seinen minecraft kind drin ist
nein
[Musik]
also freunde der nächste youtuber ist in
scope okay ist am anfang richtig abend
geht korrekt rolex nein alles klar
korrekt also im jahr was mit fitness
korrekt wenn ich jetzt keinen punkt
machte aber du machst jetzt ein punkte
das unentschieden bringt mehr zu so
freunde der verlierer muss übrigens ein
bild mit dieser brille
nein sein intro dieses zuschauer da habe
ich wohl wieder geworden
[Musik]
der nächste den ich mir ausgesucht haben
ist luca schrägstrich von crafter würde
ich auf jeden fall sagen kleine rohde im
was ja was miley nein pizza diese
ukulele richtig nein ich habe jetzt
pizza erraten und du hast kollege
erwarten aber du hast schon zweimal
geraten ich bin jetzt gerade beim zeit
anhalten
ich würde sagen ein alpaka das ist
richtig weil ja mein alter
[Musik]
wieso gibt es sieben wenn jetzt ein tipp
lukas schott bist du [ __ ] er sagt so
us-klage merching gibt ihm tipps
während sony da was er sagt
bleiben wir werden nächstes justin kurtz
von wann ist das neunter märz 2017 2012
[Musik]
ja gut ich sage ja meinen videos öfter
was wir meinen musikgeschmack ist schön
die bei bushido das ist das wäre traurig
wenn ich so gegen mit nein
so outfit bewerten das trostlose ja da
wären beide dreimal geraten haben und
das 1 1 steht
würd ich sagen dass wir jetzt ein tipp
gibt und wer zuerst dreht er kriegt den
punkt an für just zum start up eu kommst
du gerade her
köln sicher
[Musik]
der nächste den ich mir ausgesucht habe
ist der perfekt an
ich bin wieder drin döner blogs kamera
die partie nein was traveling travelling
ja der reis auch immer rum oder nicht
naja minecraft in minecraft ja ja ja
[Musik]
wir machen jetzt das letzte starter pack
freunde und diese starter pack ich werde
jetzt einmal sagen es wird das alles
jetzt entscheiden
bist du bereit ja das letzte fünf punkte
federn habe ich für euch babys beauty
palace linke babys beauty palace würde
ich sagen ja korrekt vor julia encke
geld korrekt ja alle hier freuen sie
nicht dabei geld ist dabei und ihr
schmeckt ja ein produkt sind meist
trocken
irgendwie die abo oder krieg zahl
[Musik]
das war richtig synchron das was ihr vom
video meine damen und herren ich habe
die youtuber starter packs erraten
schädlich gegenschatz den wollen wer
hätte gedacht dass ich verliere ich doch
keiner us car dazu